the tax laws of this country are a
disgrace to the human race
our tax system could only be described
as un-american
read my lips
taxes they're in every four years
campaign trail issue
and just like most modern day candidates
joe biden
campaigned on big ambitions his
to tax the rich give money to the middle
class and
roll back some parts of president
trump's tax overhaul
we don't need a tax code that rewards
wealth
more than it rewards work he wants to
terminate the tax cuts that we gave you
joe biden has been very clear
he will not raise taxes on anybody who
makes less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year appeal the trump tax cuts
mr vice president i'm speaking biden
isn't proposing to repeal the entire tax
law
but now that he's president-elect the
reality of u.s politics is setting in
if democrats don't have the senate the
tax increases
are almost certainly not happening it's
that simple
democrats have kept their majority in
the house but
in order for them to gain control of
congress they need to win
two more senate seats which will be
decided in two january runoff races in
georgia
still biden would have to get every
single democratic senator on board with
his proposals
and in the end any changes he's able to
make to the tax code
could look pretty different than the
controversial proposals we heard about
on the campaign trail
so just how likely is biden's tax plan
to become a reality
first let's look at how it could affect
your wallet biden campaign when he was
running really drew this
as much of a bright line at four hundred
thousand dollars of income as they could
four hundred thousand four hundred
thousand dollars a year four hundred
thousand dollars
more than ninety eight percent of
households are below four hundred
thousand dollars so
tax rates and deductions and
big changes that would raise your tax
bill largely
don't affect you if you're below 400 000
of income
the details of exactly how much tax
rates might change are still hard to pin
down but we can look generally at how
biden's tax proposals might affect
different households
a low-income household doesn't pay a lot
in income taxes right now
they probably pay a fair amount in
payroll taxes
taxes on low-income families wouldn't go
up
and not much would change for
middle-income households the
tax rates wouldn't change the tax
brackets wouldn't change
the major deductions wouldn't change the
biggest moves in the 2017 tax law don't
expire until the end of 2025 and at this
point i really wouldn't expect congress
to do much about them
in the in the near term biden has
proposed a number of tax credits that
could give money back to low and
middle-income households
he wants to raise the child tax credit
from two thousand dollars to three
thousand dollars a child or
more for young children under the age of
six families can currently get up to
roughly a thousand dollars per child
through the child and dependent care tax
credit
biden has proposed raising that to a
maximum of four thousand dollars a child
and first-time home buyers could get an
advanceable tax credit
of up to fifteen thousand dollars under
biden's proposed first
down payment tax credit but like we said
the biggest proposed changes would
impact income above four hundred
thousand dollars
yeah high income households if you're
making over 400 000
they want to raise your taxes they want
to raise the tax rates on ordinary
income
they want to get rid of the special new
20
deduction for business income again like
these are the the things that would mark
significant tax increases on high income
households
what we don't know is whether they're
going to be able to get any of them in
place
another major part of biden's tax plan
is corporate taxes
while much of trump's signature tax
policy cut taxes on corporations
biden plans to raise them the buying
approach on taxing businesses is to
basically say the 2017 tax law went too
far
biden's proposal would put the corporate
tax rate at 28 percent
plus any state or local income taxes
that's higher than it is now but not as
high as it was during the obama
administration
a 28 baseline corporate tax rate would
still be higher than the average rate
globally
and major industrialized economies like
hong kong
the uk south korea and canada
one of biden's proposals would put a
minimum tax on companies
so that all large corporations pay at
least some federal taxes
essentially getting rid of instances
where companies like amazon
chevron and starbucks can sometimes pay
an effective u.s
tax rate of zero percent or less
according to their financial statements
why that's possible now is complicated
congress offers companies tax breaks for
investing in things like research and
development and capital equipment
taking those incentives away would
require a delicate balancing act
you know this this idea that congress is
trying to like it's in some ways like
sort of trying to do two things at once
it's like provide these incentives but
then also take them away and so that's
that's going to be a
a tricky thing to kind of work through
once they
go from campaign sound bite into details
on that and
corporate taxes don't just affect people
at the very top
if you're making 150 000 and you
have a 401k and there's corporate shares
in there
then clearly to the extent that
corporate taxes go up corporations are
less profitable
they're worthless that affects the value
of your shares
and so so there's a burden on you from
these tax changes
even if you're not directly having to
pay out more money biden's approach is
to try and line up permanent new
spending with tax increases
the university of pennsylvania ran the
numbers and estimated that biden's plan
would raise 3.375 trillion dollars in
new revenue over 10 years
while increasing spending by 5.37
trillion
so the tax hikes wouldn't cover
everything
and they need to think that through as
they write out the details
economists generally agree that
increased taxes lower economic growth
but by exactly how much is up for debate
of course all of this debate over the
tax code is happening in the middle of a
pandemic
and economic recession in the short term
the government is prioritizing putting
money in people's pockets so they can
make ends meet
that means tax cuts for low and
middle-income americans
could be easier to enact quickly because
they can be tacked onto coronavirus
stimulus
measures but raising corporate and high
income taxes
which is part of biden's long-term plan
at a time when
so many businesses are struggling could
be tricky regardless of who holds power
in the senate in terms of tax increases
it depends on really whether democrats
have the senate
and if they do they're going to face an
interesting choice which is
do they make those tax increases
effective
january of 2021 or do they kind of say
all right well we know the economy is a
little bit weak now and we'll sort of
have them kick in in 2022 or later and
that's something they haven't really
settled on yet
one way the biden administration could
enact some change without congressional
approval
is through regulation rather than
changing the tax law directly
the biden administration could use its
regulatory powers to change how the law
is interpreted
one can imagine by an administration
going in there and saying all right well
you know think on this definition for
how foreign income of u.s companies is
taxed they kind of went too far and
we're going to take some of that back
another tactic biden could take is
beefing up the irs
by asking congress for more money to
fund the agency
which could then spend more time on
enforcement and litigation
there's gonna be a lot to do a lot to
think about and and we'll just sort of
gauge these two big uncertainties which
are what the state of the pandemic and
economy look like
and what the state of the senate looks
like it's it's this odd moment where we
have
so much new clarity because we know the
election result and yet they're the
still
because life is uncertain there's still
still these big
uncertainties out there